[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
investigations editor for open democracy
peter gagan and the former government
advisor anita boitang they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages
the eye carries the defense secretary
ben wallace's advice to afghans looking
to flee their homeland
avoid air travel and try to use land
borders instead
that's also the lead story in the
guardian
the metro mocks the foreign secretary
dominic raab's assertion that he
couldn't leave his holiday on the island
if creta's kabul was falling because in
his words the sea was closed
the star also has that story
the telegraph has heard plans are
underway to allow 12 year olds to be
given the covid vaccine without parental
consent
the daily express also looks at covert
vaccinations with their focus on the
urgent plea to roll out booster jabs
and the financial times carries a story
about city regulators fearing they can't
properly control one of the world's
biggest cryptocurrency exchanges known
as binance
and we're joined tonight by peter gagan
and anita boateng good evening to both
of you we're going to start with the eye
and it's pretty grim advice from the
defense secretary following that updated
advice from the foreign office
in the last hour or so about the threat
of a terrorist attack at kabul airport
that people should move away to a safe
location await further advice the
defense secretary telling people
peter to forget about the airport and
try and flee via the border
yes we have ben wallace who has been a
briefing to mps has said that there's
only a few flights places left on
british rescue flights so that means
there's going to be you know
probably you know hundreds if not more
um british citizens and afghans who
trying to get to you back to the united
kingdom that are going to really
struggle to get out and
it really does show just how
disastrous the situation is you know
we're hearing talk american at the top
of your program about a humanitarian
crisis and what i think today's front
pages are showing is just how the lack
of control that you know that we've seen
in the last few days if anything seems
to be getting worse
you know only yesterday we're talking
about 72 hours but now it feels like in
afghanistan things are happening at
almost warp speed you know two weeks ago
it was three or four weeks before kabul
would fall and now we're talking about
effectively and the british government
telling people not to go to the airport
telling britain's not to go to the
airport and to try and find third
countries out
to do
anita we've we've had the pentagon
earlier on saying evacuations will be
continuing until
at the end of the month but we know that
the civilian evacuations have to end
before that if you to get all the troops
out but now it seems that this security
threat the threat of terrorism is
accelerating the situation yet further
absolutely and i think the challenge um
is actually from isis that they may take
some action um in order to disrupt the
activity in the airport which as paul
says is already incredibly chaotic i
think it's very clear that part of the
you know the political push particularly
from the us to ensure that there is this
deadline
of you know symbolic relevance to the
united states to get um troops out has
exacerbated what you would expect around
kind of the usual disruption that is
involved in evacuating and getting out
the number of people um that is required
and it does seem as though there's even
indications that the uk could be
withdrawing as early as this friday so
it's really becoming incredibly chaotic
incredibly panicked and actually um
there's a lot of reports of people who
are staying in their homes because they
don't feel it's safe to go to the
airport or it was irrespective of what
we're hearing tonight about the possible
threats from isis
i think that's the gap isn't it peter
between what we're being told by
particularly by the us by president
biden about you know get people to the
airport and we will try to get you out
and the situation on the ground when
people literally cannot get to the
airport
well just a few months ago joe biden was
asked about this the famous um airlift
act of saigon kind of heralded the end
of the us involvement in vietnam in 1975
and said you know nothing like that will
happen in in afghanistan it would be a
very orderly withdrawal you know and we
are looking at anything but an orderly
withdrawal it's incredibly disorderly
it's quite clear that you know whatever
planning was done was nowhere near
sufficient and it's actually even quite
striking that it's not just in
afghanistan we're saying that like an
open democracy today we ran a story
about a flight and evacuation flight
from afghanistan that sat in the tarmac
for 24 hours in birmingham actually even
longer than that where some mix of you
know afghan nationals and british
citizens were left effectively stranded
with little food or water and access to
sanitation so it seems to be chaotic
across the piece um and if anything you
know
what's going to happen on the 31st of
august which is the the pull-out date um
you know it begs the question you know
quite how chaotic it could become and
the threat from isis and other terrorist
organizations you know is
also hardly kind of a new and novel
phenomenon this is something that has
been aware of you know since for a very
long time so i think you know whatever
happens on the back of this there needs
to be a massive post-mortem into just
how this chaotic how this situation was
allowed to take place in the in the
first place um this story on the front
of the guardian as well head for the
border uk tells afghans trying to flee
and then what anita
that's exactly it it does feel as though
part of the challenge and when we talk
about intervention we tend to focus
quite a lot on what happens when you do
act but there is a kind of challenge of
what you do when when you don't act like
what are the kind of investments and
support you're giving to neighbouring
countries that allows this to really
work in a way that is is joined up and i
think that um you know the guardian's
got a great story kind of covering some
of the challenges that that might arise
as a result of heading in back to the
border rather than trying to get a
flight out of afghanistan
yeah and and the prospects for those who
either flee to a third country
or those who decide they have no option
but to stay in
afghanistan are getting bleaker by the
minute aren't they peter with those
warnings from the world food programme
today about the humanitarian crisis the
risk of starvation
yes it's quite clear as it seems to be
both a humanitarian crisis on on the
cusp of unfolding in afghanistan and
also there's going to be a lot of people
who have helped the what would be seen
as the occupation forces for the last
two decades you know just today i had
contact with somebody who's worked for
on a differed project you know on an aid
and british aid project in afghanistan
who's trying to get out of kabul with
his family and is fearful for his life
we're already hearing stories that you
know the taliban have said that they're
going to be
merciful and that they're not going to
seek vengeance but we're already hearing
stories of summary executions of people
who work with the coal with the you know
american and british forces in
afghanistan and it is it just begged
that huge question 20 years on what um
what has been achieved what's been
achieved by the past 20 years in
afghanistan what's been achieved by you
know the invasion and the huge amounts
of money that went into it but also if
we're if we are on the cusp of a
humanitarian disaster well how are we
how is the world going to react to that
how is it going to engage you know in
many ways the taliban were empowered
last year by donald trump when they had
the doha agreement um in which basically
effectively it was agreed that the
taliban will be able to take over
afghanistan and the american forces
would leave so having empowered the
taliban i guess the question is now does
the international community and does
um the americans and and whose electric
extended british have any uh of any sway
over the taliban and to to force them to
like to actually even help you know
we've there was a large play made last
week by dominic rabbit they're going to
increase aid spending by 10 to
afghanistan having cut it by 80 percent
earlier this year there's a big question
about how will aid spending be possible
at all in afghanistan in the back of
this
let's talk a little bit more about
dominic raab uh he features on the front
of a couple of the papers today let's
have a look at the metro paddle b likely
now dominic rob of course is the taliban
were arriving at the gates of kabul was
on holiday
he has defended that decision today
defended himself anita against claims
that he was
on the beach and paddle boarding what's
he had to say
well i think he essentially said that it
was all nonsense that a lot of the
detail that had emerged to add sort of
color to to the story that he was
paddling for instance um was nonsense he
said that the sea was closed um that
that day so presumably he couldn't have
been um paddleballing i think his point
was simply that he felt like a lot of
the the coverage of this just wasn't
accurate um look i have some sympathy
with with the foreign secretary in the
sense that this does feel as though it
is a big distraction as a result of the
fact that we as as journalists as the
commentary feel quite powerless in when
we're watching the kind of harrowing
scenes of afghanistan and i think there
is a natural urge to kind of be like
what could have been you know who hasn't
been doing their job who can we blame
and i think the question about how much
of a difference whether this you know
whether there was someone on the other
end of the line even for the foreign
secretary to call um i think has sort of
you know we've distracted ourselves a
little bit well i mean it wasn't just
the foreign secretary was it was the
senior civil servants at the foreign
office at the home office etc as well
there was a feeling that there was a a
vacuum of power at a point at which key
decisions needed to be made
to help those people in afghanistan
and what i would say is i think that
there is a definite challenge
from that we can issue to the foreign
office which is around like what is the
policy what is the approach to
intervention when you're in a context
where the intelligence seems to have
been um a little unclear and where we're
so reliant on the us what is the uk's
role going to be and i think there are
some really substantial questions and i
hope some substantial lessons that the
foreign office can take from this i
think um the questions around like
physical presences in different offices
it seems to be slightly separate because
it does feel as though officials and in
particular soldiers have been working
around the clock in afghanistan to help
people most in need
uh yeah um let's just have a look at the
star uh peter shall we because it's like
the metro is having a bit of fun with
this quite an image uh it has on its
front page of the foreign secretary on
his paddle board which he said he
couldn't be on because the the sea was
closed the point is
this isn't going away for dominic raab
is it
no and i'll try and not go
go to to read the the headline myself at
least i slip up upon it but no i don't
think it will and i think i think
anish's point is fair like you know in
many ways this is um you know it's it's
quite fun to think of dominic rob and
wayne's holidays and it begs all sorts
of questions about what he was doing and
what he wasn't doing but i think it
actually the reason why it resonates is
probably less you know it's
less to do with the specifics of crete
and whether the the sea was closed or
not in a given day which is quite you
know it seems to be quite a factual
comment for someone to make but more to
do with the fact of what was the foreign
secretary's policy in this area you know
he's been the foreign secretary for
quite a long time he was a foreign
secretary when the doha agreement was
signed what was his views then what were
britain's views on the signing of a
peace day with the taliban but by the
trump administration you know was was
there any you know was there any um
um kind of push back against us you know
what what was that what was happening
there like what was the policy um
for afghanistan we've had an integrated
review recently which is basically very
much pivo around the idea of global
britain post-brexit britain's role in
the world and i think we're getting a
real dose of real politic here which is
that it's fine to write policy papers
talking about britain's role in the
world but actually what britain's been
left doing for the last week is kind of
pleading with the americans to please
not go so soon and the americans saying
we don't really care what you think and
i'm doing it anyway and britain is left
trying to mop it up um and so you know
whether dominic rabb was not on holiday
or not on holiday probably wouldn't have
made a huge difference over the last
week or so but whether he was actually
completely engaged with this issue in
the last year or so probably would have
and then the americans of course be just
saying well it's not up to us now anyway
it's up to the taliban at the situation
that we now find ourselves in peter
anita we're just going to take a brief
pause coming up
should 12 year olds be able to get the
covered vaccine without parental consent
we'll be discussing that next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now peter gagan and
anita boiteng
turning to coronavirus which is also on
the front of several papers today
peter at the daily express urgent plea
to roll out booster jabs now this is uh
following studies showing that vaccine
protection can decline after six months
yeah so we're seeing a kind of you know
unsurprisingly this is com similar
conversations happen in other countries
too where this you know where they're
quite
pronounced around the rollouts kind of
quite far on it similarly happened in
israel a few months ago where the
efficacy of
almost all vaccines to different extents
does seem to decrease after a period of
time and after six months it decreases
quite dramatically although it still
seems that vaccinations will still
protect people against um severe illness
and property debt as well which is a
good thing and so the conversation now
is turning to boosters so it's
interesting to see this is becoming a
big kind of issue already you know the
world health organization has said that
like really at the moment the the issue
isn't boosters for the developed world
it's actually vaccines for
the underdeveloped world you know and
because what we're seeing is actually in
across the west does that we all there's
enough vaccines for everyone who wants
them the issue is still getting enough
people to take them but in the in in
other parts of the world quickly in
african countries there's really really
low levels of vaccination and real kind
of concerns of 20 2022 could actually
see much higher rates go with debt than
even 2021 or 2020 because of this
because of a lack of vaccination so it's
kind of interesting what we're kind of
having this conversation about let's
let's roll out boosters and
so far the medical opinion seems to be
quite mixed on this some people are
suggesting they might be needed others
are suggesting it's too early perhaps
we'll see
just pretty older age group rolled out
wish the flu vaccine too but a lot of
that still seems to be kind of up in the
air to be decided yeah anita this is
also on the front of the telegraph and
we're expecting a jcvi announcement
within the coming days on whether the
booster uh program is is going to go
ahead and what form it will be because a
debate now over whether you give
boosters to the over 50s for example or
whether you vaccinate at 12 year olds
and and upwards as we've seen in other
countries
yes or indeed you know whether you do
both or neither um it does feel as
though um the the plans for a third
booster um are much more developed than
this possibility of 12 um to 15 year
olds being vaccinated so it does feel as
though that would be the natural next
step though as you say we wait for the
jcbi um who advise the government on
such matters to make a final um decision
and so it does feel as though the
priority will probably be around the
most vulnerable people now obviously as
we're seeing a return to schools we've
had summer festivals we will have more
people indoors um in september i think
cases we do expect them to rise and
mobile scientists do and therefore i
think this conversation particularly
around schools and how you ensure that a
number of people can obviously stay in
school and protect the vulnerable and
that conversation will continue and
it'll be very interesting to see where
it ends up anita peter thank you very
much indeed and